في طريقه إلى الجبهة في واحدة من أكثر
المناطق نشاطًا في الحرب الوحشية في
أوكرانيا مع فريق مدفعية صاروخي
يستهدف قوات فلاديمير بوتين
التي يطلق عليها كارلسون ويستخدمون
شاحنات خفيفة مزودة بأقراص صواريخ مثبتة على
السرير تحمل الصواريخ رسالة مفادها أن
تم توقيع هذا الانتقام نيابة عن
جندي سقط بسبب حماقة من
الساحرة ، حيث يقول إن
السيارة فعالة للغاية لأننا نستطيع
أن نطلق النار بسرعة ونهرب
مرة أخرى
الآن وهم يستهدفون مواقع روسية على
بعد عدة أميال ،
لكن المدفعية الروسية هي أيضًا  خطير
ويمكن أن يرد بسرعة
، فليس آمنًا ، إنه يصرخ أنه يجب أن
يخرج من هنا بأسرع ما يجب علينا الخروج
من هنا بأسرع ما يمكن لأن
الروس قد يستهدفون هذا الموقع
بعد أن يصطدموا بسالفو من
صواريخنا.
الدقة تأتي من الهواء ، حيث
تقوم الطائرات بدون طيار بإخراج النطاقات من الهدف ثم
تراقب بينما تضرب المدفعية
ورشة إصلاح عسكرية روسية ، تقول الوحدة
إننا أعين الوحدة التي نقوم بإعادة
نشرها  CE ثم تأكد من
إصابة الهدف ،
يتعرض الروس لمثل هذا الضغط ،
حيث بدأوا في إجلاء عشرات
الآلاف من الأشخاص من أغنيتها ،
ويعتقد الأوكرانيون أن موسكو
تدلي بادعاءاتها التي لا أساس لها من الصحة بشأن
استعداد كييف لاستخدام ما يسمى بالقنبلة القذرة
لأن  القوات الروسية متمركزة
في هذه المنطقة
يعتقد قائد كارسون أنها
مسألة وقت فقط قبل أن يطردوا
جيش فلاديمير بوتين من هنا
بحلول نهاية العام ، نعتقد أن حسن
سيكون تحت الأعلام الأوكرانية
ويأملون أن تحدث وحدتهم
فرقًا بسيطًا في  المعركة من أجل ابنها